meine damen und herren wir sind gls
german life star heute sind wir bei easy
german carina willkommen bei einer neuen
episode von abdul und alles klar
keiner hat schon fragen bekommen und wir
sollen diese fragen beantworten und wie
können wir wissen die frage noch nicht
also für so spontan und dann absolut und
alle antworten
ihr müsst jetzt die fragen von easy
german zuschauern waren ja gar frage
nummer 1 gut hier gut thierry fragt wie
viel zeit braucht man um gut durch zu
können
doch eine reihe wochen meiner meinung
nach ist ein zwei wochen gut deutsch
können reicht oder also für mich war das
so ungefähr ein jahr und da habe ich
dann cas abgelehnt gelegt abgelegt
abgelehnt abgelehnt
als ein jahr glaube ich auch also ich
habe die b 2 prüfung abgelegt nach 388
monaten und das hat geklappt also
bezwang ist so gut durch aber ist okay
ja ich weiß er hat probleme manchmal
reden die deutschen miteinander während
der mahlzeiten oder sind sie total still
ein freund sagte mir dass die leute in
dänemark gar nicht reden und dass wir in
brasilien während des essens zu viel
miteinander reden
ich würde gerne wissen wie das bei den
deutschen ist danke also wir sind
überhaupt gar kein deutscher wir haben
aber unser eigener meinung aber du
kannst vielleicht anfangen was sagst du
dazu
na ja gut es kommt darauf an wo man es
wagt er schon mal bei deutschen zu essen
also ich habe auch erfahrungen ja die
reden während die ersten ich glaube ja
aber nicht so viel aber im vergleich mit
uns ja oder so die reden endlich so
richtig richtig heftig beim essen also
manchmal die ersten überhaupt nicht nur
reden ich meine manchmal besser
wahrscheinlich freue mich wenn ich bei
deutschen so eingeladen bin
das gut die rentenkasse der ganze zeit
das ist schon oder aber zb bei uns wenn
wenn so hammer beim essen sitzen aus
unserem gefühl ist ja genau
wir denken dass wir streiten über das
essen das das ist gut das ist scheiße
und so eine aber eigentlich da sagen das
ist lecker das ist noch besser und das
ist ja das kommt nicht weg die beste
frau oder so man muss immer das fragen
wer hat das gekocht auch wenn man das
weiß man muss das fragen was du damit
man halt doch stolz auf sich ja ja also
ich hab das gekocht und dann kommt mir
so mama kocht und dann sagen lenker auch
wenn das nicht lecker ist gut hatte ich
immer in deutschland warte ich noch mal
zum essen eingeladen und habt was
gegessen was ihr ganz ekelig findet ja
was ich weiss nicht irgendwas mit
kartoffel also heute hier das essen ist
immer kartoffeln egal was was damit
kartoffelbrot mit von kartoffeln ganz
offen mit kartoffeln es ist etwas was
der sonst nur kartoffeln dieser welt
eine frage an euch ja als von firas
syhre vielleicht ist das viel hass auf
syrien
ich glaube schon bei der stellensuche es
war schon von ali k ich habe eine frage
warum sind fast alle lampen und
glühbirnen hier in deutschland geld bei
uns in syrien benutzen wir eine weiße
leuchte natürlich nur wenn strom da ja
wohl
und das wirklich gemütlicher als das
gelbe licht es klingt banal aber ich
glaube es ist ein echtes progressiv
einer der großes problem in deutschland
dieses die politiker musste
zusammensitzen und in der bundestag will
sich entscheiden kein keine gelbes licht
mehr
das ist gefährlich für die gesellschaft
gefährlicher für die kinder halt dass
zum beispiel das ist glaube ich gelb das
ist megageil oder das ist schon geil ich
kenne den unterschied
also gehen das geld zum beispiel das
licht ist so das ist es richtig weiß was
er weiß
weiß ist haben wir im studio bei uns
doch als ich nach deutschland kam man
habe ich gemerkt dass die die gelbe
lichter blitzen und ich habe ich konnte
nicht studiert und ich bin nicht lernen
durch lehren das macht mich mit ihr
geschlafen ich mache nicht leben
mein leben war sehr sehr sehr zerstört
sondern deutschland es auch geld als
bundesweiter ist so raiffeisen sonne ist
weiß deswegen nur den mund genau nur
einmal gibt es ein test wie gut ihr
deutsch sprechen abdul ahmad ja wohl
alle reserven können sie mir mal
erklären was ist der unterschied
zwischen wirkung auswirkungen ein
wirkung beeinflussen und welches von
ihnen heißt impact auf englisch ich muss
jetzt leider los glaube ich viel spaß da
wird also ein wirken ist ich versuch's
mal einwirken ist wenn man sowas in ein
zum beispiel den mann hat man muss
klamotten waschen und sie werden erst
ist das ein drittel so seine tücken ist
ja weiß ich auch nicht wenn das ist okay
man braucht da hab ich nie passiert okay
jetzt kann ein wichtiges eine wichtige
frage was sind die größten von austin
mittel aber ich habe ihn schon gefragt
er meint die längsten wörter die du
kennst die in der alltagssprache benutzt
werden heißt also ja ich habe ein video
gedreht auf der straße und die leute
haben angehört hat für uns geschrieben
und das wahlmaterial nation
bescheinigung hat situation ist ja das
längste wurde das ich kenne ja also ich
weiß was sie will bedeutet wenn man an
der uni immatrikuliert ist und auch
diese immatrikulationsbescheinigung es
gibt noch ein richtig so ein dankeswort
und das heißt
daueraufenthaltsgenehmigung
daueraufenthaltsgenehmigung und wenn man
in berlin eine wohnung sucht muss man
meistens bewerbung für eine wohnung eine
mietschuldenfreiheitsbescheinigung
vorlegen
dh dass man keine alten mietschulden hat
bei einem anderen vermieter demokratie
ist so
würde ich sagen das war's schon in
unserer ich lese jetzt mal kommentare
von euch vor ihr seid großartig
sie verschreibt wir bayern sind
kulturell ja er aber als deutsche
dass das stimmt nicht also er sei kein
araber kein deutsch essen
er hat ganz andere kultur ganz andere
sprache
ich weiß nicht warum habt ihr keine
eigene grenze dass gott sei dank
das glaube ich schon auch aber was gibt
es noch eine separate ich kann das auch
lesen
das klingt ja schon okay das ist kein
gutes wort ein negativer kommentar
danke ich könnte du musst du bist
unlustig auch das gold fürs grobe
es waren wenn dein kumpel los muss ja es
hätte eigentlich guck mal german life
style also wir sind german life style
gls wir haben eine seite in facebook und
einen youtube kanal und wir machen so
verschiedene videos dies geht hier um
deutschland unsere leben in deutschland
wir sind zwei flüchtlinge syrische
flüchtlinge
wir sind flüchtlinge keine angst ja okay
also wir machen videos wie man die
sprache lernt wie man die regel hier
kennen lernt wie man an das klang
gewöhnen
schön das war schön danke dass ihr dabei
gewesen seit wir bedanken uns auch bei
ihnen
also ich bin nicht ich bin ein bisschen
respekt vor unserer kamera ja meister
genau und was vielleicht in youtube auch
schauen oder stellt sein werden noch
sehr viele witzige sachen jetzt bald da
könnt ihr also also da kann man jetzt
noch gar nicht mitrechnen was da noch
alles kommen wird dass es wieder richtig
glaubt risiko wegen unglaublich bin ich
ja wenn ich meiner familie erzählen
ich weiß nicht was da passiert aber 41
cousinen weil im einfluss des q7 was
sagt das ist immer so eine in wasser
haben ja eine große gruppe 40 personen
dass alle ab basis ab basis familie und
das macht mich fertig danke dass ihr da
war schön danke fürs zuschauen und
praktizieren
ja unbedingt um auf jeden fall unbedingt
das thema nicht noch mal
jaja das dauert noch paar tage noch
arbeiten dass unser licht nicht normal
ist ist es nicht normal das macht unser
leben kaputt so dann so